hi this is Ryan and you're watching my
tutorial on Java in a moment we are
going to build an entire application
from start to finish and I'm going to be
with you typing it out and explaining
how it works the whole time now this
video is a free complement to my course
working class Java I prefer to teach
people by building things because that's
mostly how I learned I don't have a
degree in anything but I want to make
sure you have answers to questions like
when exactly do I use an interface or an
abstract class is there really such a
thing as the perfect software
architecture chances are you want the
answer to that question because that is
the most common question I have been
asked from the thousands of people that
I have taught over the years so in this
video we are going to write code and
solve specific problems I will include
overlays which will point you to lessons
in the course which explain in simple
language and I do mean that virtually
every concept from absolute beginner to
things which even senior Java developers
are not sure on believe me if you make
it through these two learning resources
you will have everything I wish I had as
a beginner
all I ask is that you follow along with
me during the practical lessons even if
they do not make sense at first sound
fair enough great let's get started I
don't care whether you are a UI UX
designer an app developer or a database
administrator every app you build starts
with some form of problem domain
analysis BOM domain analysis which I
discuss in detail in working class Java
can be summarized by asking two simple
questions what data does my app need to
represent what problems does my app need
to solve for its users in this lesson we
will build the first few classes for the
Sudoku game these classes are very much
like the foundation of a building as we
will build the rest of the application
on top of them so I've created a new
project in IntelliJ IDEA and I'm just
to correct the package name here and
we'll delete the sample FX ml file
that's one way in which you can build a
user interface in Java FX but we're
going to do it programmatically in Java
instead yeah we won't need that
controller class and also we will work
on creating the main class properly in a
different video when we talk about
application containers so what we're
going to focus on in this video like I
say is the classes within the problem
domain so the first one we're going to
build is just a virtual representation
of a Sudoku game as you can see here
so this thing here gamestate is actually
going to be an enum that we will create
in the next lesson represents different
states of a game it's my codes usually
pretty easy to read
I represent the actual Sudokus grid the
puzzle itself as a two-dimensional array
as you can see here and this is actually
just a constant which I use throughout
the application you'll notice that I
forgot to write int I will fix that
eventually but yeah 9 of course
represents the number of squares in a
Sudoku puzzle now I'm hitting alt insert
here and that's allowing IntelliJ to
open up a dialog to generate my
constructor and some getters for the
getter for the grid state I'm actually
going to make it sort of immutable and
what I mean by that is we're not
actually going to just return grid state
here we're going to return a copy of
grid state a little mistake there how
I'm going to do that is I've I will we
will eventually create this class called
Sudoku utilities which has a static
function or method which will create a
copy of that given array this basically
protects this Sudoku game object from
being messed with or changed over time
and then we're also going to add
implements serializable here this is
just so that I can read and write this
particular game data file to a file on
the operating system easier we'll talk
about all that later and there we go
fixing the mistake there so the next
thing we're gonna build is a little
class here called coordinates and it's
just going to contain an X and a y value
and some interesting functions which we
will use with our hash map
implementation when we're at the user
interface by the way there's a whole
bunch of things going on here for
beginners there's you see private you
see final you see static I talked about
all of this stuff in working class Java
so do consider checking out the course
so we're just going to make a
constructor and some getters would be
useful as well and then we're going to
also add in some functions now or what
say functions I mean methods every heir
of their language basically calls them
functions so what we have here this
equals method comes from the object
class in Java which every every class
extends from object implicitly and the
reason why we're doing this is we want
to be able to store these coordinate
objects in a hash map we're actually
going to basically be using them as keys
to key keep track of different UI
elements anyways I'll talk about that
more when we actually get to it got a
little a reference to some Snoop Dogg
here this and that it's like this and
like that unlike this Sena sorry I
apologize I grew up on gangster rap
alright so yeah nothing super
interesting going on here just a whole
bunch of boilerplate code do try to
follow along because as you can see here
I'm not copy and pasting anything and it
is my intention that you follow along
with this tutorial now the other thing
we're going to implement is a hash code
function so basically what a hash code
is it's kind of like a unique identifier
which is generated from some kind of
data that you give it so what we're
gonna do is we're just gonna take the x
and y value and we're going to use this
objects hash function and what that's
gonna do is it will generate a unique
identifier from the specific X&Y value
of the specific coordinates thing like I
say we'll see more about that later and
then you might be wondering why am i
creating an interface here I actually
decided on this interface during my
problem domain analysis stage a cool way
to use interfaces is to is to design
parts of your application upfront ahead
of time this is called design by
contract or code to an interface or
whatever also I'm anticipating i/o
exceptions because this is an i/o device
and yeah this is just basically read and
write nothing else going on here if
you're wondering about interfaces I go
into great detail in them in part 4 of
my course that's
all for now as discussed extensively in
part two of working-class Java we can
ask a few simple questions about our
data to best determine how to model it
two great tools for modeling data which
does not change throughout the runtime
of the application our static final
variables and enums the gamestate enum
is rather self-explanatory it basically
represents different potential states
that the game might be in so we have
complete active and new and we will see
in later parts of this tutorial or a
lesson series here where that kind of
comes into play we're also going to make
a couple different constants for
different messages which will pop up in
the application in this case this is
just going to be a message that will pop
up when the user wins a game and I'll
have like a little dialogue alert dialog
pop up I'll show you how to do that when
we build the user interface and it's
just gonna display a nice message here
congratulations you have one new game
and we'll also do a quintessential error
message here always good to let the user
know that an error has occurred also it
took me a minute to remember how
occurred was spelled and there's only
one thing left to build which is another
enum this time actually just selecting
them there and this one's called rows
all this is for is legibility concerns
and you will see how that helps us way
later on that's it for this one every
application needs an entry point we will
now set up an entry point for our Sudoku
application in JavaFX now we're going to
rename this class main here to Sudoku
application and you'll see in a minute
we'll actually create a new main class
now this main class here exists purely
for convenience to be able to actually
launch this application from IntelliJ
IDEA the reason for it is
if we try to actually just run launch
our sodoku application then there will
be a crash so what we do is we invoke
from here first and then in this main
method we will actually call the main
method within sodoku application which
we will see in a minute but this is
purely for a convenience sake some
lightning fast typing skills here eh so
within sodoku application other than
fixing some typing errors we're just
going to get set up here
oh sorry didn't mean to yell so the
first thing we're gonna add here is a
reference to AI user interface contract
dot view which actually is the user
interface notice how I like to prefix
interfaces with AI and then I will
suffix their implementations with UI
imple energist impulse pacifically so UI
imple will be creating very shortly
which represents the actual user
interface this stage object that we're
passing to it is basically a simple
window which JavaFX gives us so that we
can modify it and the sodoku build logic
class will be actually writing that
class at the very end it contains the
build logic which is kind of like what
you would see with a dependency
injection type set up the code required
to wire things together now that
operation could potentially fail so we
are ready to catch an i/o exception if
that does actually occur also I didn't
have to actually write the main method
in this application class because it was
automatically generated by IntelliJ IDEA
but I'll just scroll down to show you
you'll need to have that setup down
there in case you're writing this all
manually so the next thing we're going
to do is we are going to figure out how
to import Java FX into our IntelliJ
project here so go to file project
structure click on libraries hit the
plus button hit java and then what you
do is you'll select the lib folder in
the Java FX SDK you will have to
download that but that's all we're doing
here go ahead and click OK and I hit OK
again and now you can see application
has been imported properly and we're all
done ok we are now going to build the
user interface for this Sudoku game
please be aware that I designed the user
interface ahead of time using envision
now before we get to actually
implementing the user interface I
actually like to design it and the class
that will talk to using Java interfaces
now if you have any confusion over when
to use interfaces or how they work and
the same goes for abstract classes I
explain this very
and very simply in working-class Java
and I really mean that I don't use a ton
of words to explain it it's really quite
simple if someone gives just a clear
explanation which is pretty rare anyways
so what we've got going on here as you
can see I've actually nested the event
listener interface in the I user
interface contract basically what I'm
doing is I'm using the parent interface
as kind of like a namespace or a way of
differentiating different interfaces so
if I had multiple different user
interface components or features this is
how I would differentiate them because
most of them would have like an event
listener and a view and then the I user
interface contract kind of points to
which part of the application for the UI
that we're talking about so it's kind of
a handy little trick there the event
listener will be something like a
controller or a presenter I like to name
things based on what they do because
typically that's the best kind of name
you can give something as for the view
anyone who's familiar with three-layer
software architectures will know that
that is basically a name for some kind
of part of the application which binds
to the user interface that's typically
what it means anyways
I also talked about three layer
architecture is a whole bunch in working
class Java including answering the
age-old question that I get asked all
the time which is the best architecture
is a mvvm MBP MVC and there is an answer
it might not be the answer you like but
I think I have a pretty good answer to
that question in any case I explain the
fundamentals of all the different types
of architectures preferences aside now
do notice I wrote a capital message and
show dialog there I will fix that
eventually but that was a little mistake
so what we're making now is basically a
special custom text field so text field
actually comes from JavaFX just be
careful when you're importing these
things that you're not importing the
java.awt that's a different UI library
that we're not using so the purpose of
this text field is all it does is it
maintain
an X and a y-coordinate essentially or
just a value and there's another purpose
which is that as a see in a moment by
the way I'm gonna use code generation
pretty heavily here because this is just
not the kind of thing you want to be
typing by hand honestly if you want to
do that I've mentioned it before but in
IntelliJ anyways you can hit fault
insert and that will bring up the menu
so I'm gonna override two functions from
text field and the reason for this is
that if you don't override these
functions then you get kind of strange
behavior with how can I say it when you
when the user enters a number zero
through nine into a Sudoku text box I
would get like repeat numbers and just
weird behavior so basically what this
does is it makes it so that if the user
just hits one on a text field then weird
things won't happen and it will just be
a single one that's actually entered
into the text field hopefully I explain
that right now oddly enough there's
actually a second method which I need to
override now we'll see that in a minute
by the way I'll talk about reg X you can
see that square bracket zero through
nine that is what's known as a regular
expression you're going to want to look
that up and know a little bit about it
it can be really ugly to write but it's
basically a way of matching strings so
what that means above is we're saying if
the string s matches any of the numbers
zero through nine then that expression
will evaluate true raiga can get really
ugly but it's basically just a way of
matching text and stuff like that
there's other ways you can do this but
reg X although it's annoying to write
sometimes it's usually pretty handy in
that way this is the other function for
some reason I needed to override both
replace text and replace selection and
if you're wondering about the super key
word that basically just calls the
method which I overrode from the parent
class okay so now we're going to build
the actual
user interface here now this is gonna
take a long time user interface code
very often is quite tedious to write and
for something like a Sudoku game with so
many different UI elements that
certainly applies so we're making it
extend the view con interface that we
just created event handler and key event
come from JavaFX so that's actually
actually how we listen for input from
the keyboard from the user interface all
I did there is again I clicked on the
red text and I hit alt insert and then
selected generate or implement methods
from the interfaces so again I'm just
letting the IDE do some of the work so
what I've got here so stage comes from
JavaFX again it's basically like the
window the background window for the
application and group is somewhat like a
div if you're coming from like an HTML
background a view group if you're coming
from an Android background it's
basically just a container of some kind
now here's an important question how do
we keep track of 81 different text
fields now I'm going to demonstrate the
wrong way to do it or a very tedious
verbose awful way to do it one way you
could do it is you could have a
reference variable for every single text
field so basically what we would do is a
little bit of an error there my
apologies something slipped through the
editing basically we could do it like
that 1 2 3 4 all the way up to 81 that
would be an awful thing to do it would
be incredibly verbose so I had to figure
out a way to keep track of these 81
different text fields without doing that
so what I settled on doing was using a
hash map now you if you've been
following this an order you'll know that
I overrode the equals and hashcode
functions for the coordinates and you'll
also remember that the Sudoku text field
that we just created has an X and a y
value so I'm going to store a wrap
princes to all of these different text
fields within a hashmap and we're going
to use that hash function to retrieve
and store them so you always want to be
keeping an eye out for things which are
just more elegant solutions now this
event listener class is going to be like
the controller or the presenter so this
is what we will pass events which the
user causes or propagates to and the
listener which is basically a control
logic class I call it will basically
interpret those events and pass messages
between the view the front end the UI
and the back end so there's just going
to be a little bit of boilerplate style
code here now
one thing in particular because this is
a single this application lis as a
single feature I'm including the style
information in the user interface here
if this you this application had
multiple different UI screens I would
not put it here I would put it in a
separate file and make these things
basically either protect it or public
access so that I'm not basically
redefining them in multiple different
user interface implementations but yeah
they're just stuff that I use to build
the user interface how I want
so window Y and window X dictates the X
and y position in the screen like the
actual monitor of the operating system
or computer padding we'll see that later
it's kind of like the padding between
the window and the actual Sudoku board
and the X&Y are kind of a again those
are going to be x and y values within
the window itself and the ones I'm
writing our pretty self-explanatory I'll
of course show some images of the actual
Sudoku board so you can kind of get an
idea of what it looks like
and I used this string here just for a
title
okay so we have a lot of work to do here
now I think what I'll do next is create
the constructor
I'm just moving handle down to the
bottom that's just to make it look more
like the application which has already
been written on the side which I am
basically copying from and if you're
wondering why I'm copying and doing
voiceover it's just a lot easier for me
to teach and do that at the same time
also I am NOT trying to go through this
super quickly in case you're wondering
why I'm moving so slowly okay so this is
a constructor and we assign our stage we
create a new group and then we create
our hash map and then once that's done
we jump immediately into a helper method
I don't want my methods to be any larger
than they need to be this is actually
something I go into in part 5 of working
class Java which is how to use how do we
think about software architecture in
terms of methods which in a sense
just avoid giant methods by using lots
of helper methods is what are what we're
talking about here so what I'll do is
for every kind of user interface
component in this particular screen I'm
going to create a helper method for it
and then obviously within that helper
method we will actually create it
background title sodoku board text
fields and the grid lines of the Sudoku
board and so stage show is what's going
to actually reveal the user interface
once everything has been drawn and
configured and set listener so what will
happen is we'll have our build logic
which will write in just later on
basically assign our control logic class
which is again like a controller or our
presenter to this particular view
obviously it'll be through the interface
and yeah here's where we get to the
interesting stuff so like I say this is
going to take awhile there's doing user
interface code is very often quite
tedious so the first thing we'll do is
we'll draw the grid lines
the Sudoku board these aren't especially
in top-to-bottom order so x and y will
be where we start to draw these grid
lines and obviously so as you can see
they're basically we're going to be
drawing the grid lines and just notice
that the some of the grid lines are
actually thicker than the others
so the ones which separate the different
squares are thicker and that's where we
get this if index equals two or five we
want the thickness to be a little
thicker
great alright
so when we want to actually draw these
lines we're just going to use the
rectangle class from JavaFX and what
we'll do is we'll draw the what's going
to happen in this while loop is we will
draw each line we'll do the vertical
lines and also the horizontal lines and
obviously we'll implement this getline
method in a minute so if you're kind of
wondering about what we're doing with
the x and y etc so we're basically
drawing a line and then moving it over
by 64 pixels or units whatever the units
are and then we will multiply that by
the index and then the result will be
basically a series of gridlines now the
reason why I created this grid line
method here sorry getline is that you'll
see in a minute will also try a
horizontal line and one thing you really
want to look out for and this is again
something I go into in working-class
Java is you want to look for repetitious
code so originally I had this code for
both the vertical and the horizontal
lines in the previous method we were
just writing which we'll get back to in
a minute and then I realized hey that's
basically the same code except the only
thing that the changes are some of the
variables so whenever you see that
that's usually a cue that you want to
pull that code out into a helper method
and that will reduce the number of lines
of code in your project and just make
things more legible because you're
breaking things down a lot better and
all that's going on here is we're
basically just creating and styling a
rectangle and remember it's going to be
an align even though it's a rectangle
and there is a plane flying by in the
background if you hear some background
noise
a little mistake there okay so that's
the vertical line and then what we will
work on next is the horizontal line or
lines I should say and so while we're
like I say all we're doing here is it's
basically the same code we're just going
to swap around a couple of the
parameters here arguments I should say
and that will give us our lines which
are drawn horizontally instead okay
all right so this is how we actually add
these UI elements to the the route the
group which is again kind of like a view
group or a div and this add all function
means we can basically slap any kind of
UI element in I think the route the
superclass of the UI elements I think
it's called a node and so we can add
anything which is a child class of node
don't quote me on that I'm going off of
memory there and now we're gonna draw
the text field so this is going to be
kind of interesting how we do this so
it's going to be a bit of a similar set
up so we're going to have like an x and
y origin so x and y Delta means the the
change in the x and y value and what
we'll do is we'll keep drawing these
things in increments of 64 units apart
from each other you're probably
wondering what is that Oh N squared
runtime complexity so I don't actually
go into detail about this I mention it
in working class Java this is an
advanced topic here which has to do with
data structures and algorithms but I
just wanted to mention this this is
really important especially for the
beginners listening but honestly anyone
who hasn't studied data structures and
algorithms or runtime complexity what
does that mean so there's a bird
chattering in the background sorry about
that so whenever you're using certain
patterns or structures so here we have a
nested for loop we have two loops nested
with anything within each other now
whenever you do nested loops especially
if you're doing like more than two
what's going to happen here is you want
to be very careful doing that in this
case it's fine
because we're only looping nine times
nine times so that's where we get that N
squared I can't give you a whole
introduction to runtime complexity right
now but basically if you have nest
loop's and there are different things
you can do other than nested loops but
that's a really easy example you do not
want to be working with large indexes
large numbers of elements and the reason
why is that the runtime of the
application will basically grow
exponentially quadratically in this case
relative to the number of inputs here so
and it was if you want to learn more
about that you can look up runtime
complexity and Big O notation so this
style sodoku tile method here again this
is just to pull some code outside into a
helper method so I just wanted to take
the code which is responsible for
styling a Sudoku tile and just put it in
a different helper method like I say
this just make think makes things more
legible in this particular case it
doesn't necessarily reduce the number of
lines of code but it just think makes
things more organized and legible and
I'm a big fan of organization and
legibility of course this is how we set
the font in Java FX
lay out X again that'll be like the x
and y where the particular UI element
will be drawn relative to the window I
believe in this case or the stage I
think they call it in Java FX the text
fields will be 64 by 64 their size and
this background empty is going to make
them transparent the background will be
supplied by the Sudoku board which we'll
deal with later so this is how we
actually listen for inputs from the user
set on key pressed so you'll notice
again this user interface simple class
implements the I believe it was the
event listener or event handler
interface from Java FX and so that is
exactly where we set that up so we're
passing this and the reason why we're
allowed to pass this is because this
implements event handler text field
coordinates is our hash map every time I
draw one of these text fields I add it
to my hash map and I use a coordinates
object as the key so when we use the put
function it supplies a key and a value
so the coordinates becomes the key the
text field reference becomes the value
now we're going to draw the snow cout
board which is pretty easy it's
basically just a colored rectangle
of course when you're doing user
interface code rarely has anything
really easy obviously you've got to set
the X and y values and the width and the
height and this than the other not to
mention the color
normally I have code completion on by
the way which is a lot quicker you might
also notice me making lots of kind of
little typing errors part of that is
because I have code completion on all so
part of that is because I have
relatively large fingers and I was born
with hand tremors so typing is I can
type really fast but sometimes my IQ
accuracy is not the best and in this
particular case I'm looking on the
screen off to the side most of the time
I'm type typing so that's why there's so
many different errors there it's also
because I suck but yeah just thought I
would give you some excuses in case
you're wondering ok so text obviously
this is just going to be the title which
goes below the Sudoku board that says
Sudoku
I believe set Phil actually sets the
font color it's not immediately obvious
but that's how you do that
and again we're gonna add that
particular UI element you're gonna see
root dog cat children on a doll in this
case I just have one element okay
now the background is the kind of
turquoise colored background scene is
again I think it's something kind of
like a view group it would basically be
like the the background of the
background or something equivalent to
that and so just a quick point here
you'll notice that I'm using very few
hard-coded values yeah there are a few
like I could make the font size a
hard-coded value but I'm using a lot of
static final constants and that just
makes things more legible and it's also
slightly more efficient when you really
get down to it computers are so fast
right now that certain things like that
won't cause a huge it's not necessarily
going to make things a whole lot more
efficient but it's good to get in the
habit of using the more efficient
approaches but for me legibility is a
primary concern and that's why I'm not
afraid to use things like enums when
appropriate
so for updates square this is what will
eventually be called when I just want to
update a single square after the user
has input a number rather than having to
update the whole board which we do
sometimes we're just trying to update a
single UI element appropriately I kind
of took that cue from messing around
with react j/s in which it's kind of
like a web platform for building user
interfaces and our framework I should
say and it's neat in that it will only
update the UI elements that need to be
updated instead of redrawing the whole
thing
and so text property dot set value
that's going to set the actual text
input that the user gave number from 0
through 9 update board will wholesale
update the entire board so that would
occur when the user finishes their game
or something like that starts a new game
and I forgot to copy the for loop which
was kind of silly like I say you've got
to understand that I'm my eyes are glued
to my secondary monitor while I'm typing
list of this stuff so there's gonna be
lots of little mistakes like that so for
each text field we're going to grab it
from the hashmap text field coordinates
and I can grab them by creating a new
coordinates object with a particular x
and y value and the nice thing about the
hash function which we talked about
earlier is that I basically can recreate
it any time I want as long as those
values are the same that will create the
same hash value which is quite handy
obviously get copy of grid state creates
a immutable copy of the game which is
kind of important I do talk about
immutability which is a big word for
things which don't change extensively
and that's a really important topic if
you're especially if you're like an
intermediate developer it's a really
great way to make your code more
resistant to bugs and changes and all
kinds of things here double equals error
now you'll see the if value equals zero
I set the text field to just be empty
basically zero or backspace represents
kind of like a deletion thing so I had a
little error what happened was game
state which is an enum we created wasn't
actually imported in my Sudoku game so
just importing that fixed it so what
we're doing now is we're checking if the
value either equals that empty ok so
actually let me backtrack a bit so what
we're doing here so this will this
function will basically be called when a
new game is created so you can see this
game state dot new so what's going to
happen is if we have an empty square so
if value dot equals blank then what
we'll do is we want to enable that text
field and set it to a slightly less
thick font that was really annoying to
do in Java FX so I finally actually had
to resort to using a bit of CSS here is
what's within those quotes if the number
is already colored in I don't want the
user to change it so we set disabled to
true and we also set it to a slightly
sorry I said thicker its opacity so
opaque which would be an alpha value if
you're familiar with alpha transparency
is what I'm saying now that that's done
we have the show dialog so this will get
called when the logic center of the game
the game logic indicates that the game
is actually completed properly and then
what we'll do is we will show this alert
dialog which will then I correct that
message thing there we show an alert
dialog which basically will ask the user
hey do you congratulations you won do
you want to start a new game and show on
wait will basically pause things and
wait for interface
our interaction from the user once that
occurs we can tell the listener hey on
dialog click the dialogue was clicked
the user wants to start a new game and
then the listener will figure out what
to do at that point now if there's any
kind of errors that occur so there can
be an error which occurs when we either
write or retrieve read or write the game
state from storage so if any of those
errors occur then we just want to let
the user know hey something went wrong
finally over the handle function again
this comes from event handler which is
the JavaFX
interface so this is where if the user
enters a number into a textbox that
event will pop up here and what we're
doing is we're checking the event type
and we're saying okay was it a key that
was pressed because I don't really care
about other events like mouse clicks and
things like that that's just noise if
that event matches so here's a funny
thing I'm using reg X here as I was
recording this code I had this giant if
statement full of or statements for the
number zero through nine and I was
looking at I was thinking didn't I just
use regs to do this exact thing so I
actually added this in immediately the
Reg X and that just clean this method of
a whole bunch usually there's very often
a more elegant way of dealing with
things instead of the brute force method
so value is whatever the user has
actually entered when they entered a
number source will be the UI element the
variable the the object that was
actually clicked on so that's why I'm
gonna use the event get source there to
pass that reference and it will get
passed to the handle input function
method I should say as an object a Java
object like the class and we also check
for word backspace if it's a backspace
then I want it to be treated like a zero
essentially so that's why we're passing
in zero there so if the user wants to
like clear an entry in the sodoku or
clear a sodoku square they can either
hit zero or backspace
I think that's just like a generic thing
if the user types anything else then we
just set it to empty I just want to
avoid writing numbers and stuff like
that event dot consume as far as I know
what that will do is it will just
basically once the event gets consumed
then it's not going to propagate through
the rest of the application that like
the internal code within JavaFX or any
of the other stuff and then again we're
gonna let the once the input occurs
we're gonna actually pass that input to
the control logic class which is the
listener here and we're going to say hey
at this x and y value this value was
called okay so we're now going to code
the control logic class which is again
kind of like a controller or presenter
and it basically manages the
interactions between the user and the
user interface and the back end of the
application which would be like the
computation logic so it's going to
extend the event listener interface
which we defined in the previous lesson
or video and again I'm going to hit alt
insert and that will bring up that
dialogue where I can implement the
abstract methods now just an important
note here whenever you're dealing with
like a controller or a presenter or a
view model or whatever I strongly
recommend that you communicate at least
with the back end here I communicate
with the view as well the front end
class through interfaces if you're not
going to use interfaces anywhere else
use them across very large and important
architectural boundaries across your
application this is very simple applied
solid principles and it's just a really
important thing to do a lot of people
think it's a waste of time and
I respectfully disagree because the
other thing is that it helps me to
design my application upfront without
worrying about the implementation and if
I need to change the storage
implementation
I can change it quickly and easily
without having to cause any issues in
this control logic class so what we're
doing here is when the user basically
inputs a number what we're gonna do or
deletes a number we're going to write
that to the game storage and the reason
why we're doing that is we kind of want
the game storage to be like the source
of truth in terms of the actual game
data now that can potentially fail it it
hasn't yet but you just have to be aware
that when you're using something like a
input/output system you want to code you
want your code to be capable of dealing
with any errors that might pop up
otherwise you're a bad programmer just
saying now if that writes successfully
then we create a new Sudoku game object
the reason why we create a new one is
I've designed it that way it's a it's an
immutable object and this is actually
how you work with immutable data models
is you create a new one from the old one
once we've successfully written to the
storage then we can update the view and
again like I said in the previous video
if we don't need to update the entire
user interface if we can get away with
just updating one square that is a very
much more preferable way to do things
so now what we're doing here is we're
just checking to see okay is the
gamestate complete and that will be
dictated by the code that we'll be
writing in the next video and if it is
complete then we want to show a dialogue
to the user now if for some reason
something does go wrong which is
unlikely there's not a whole lot we can
do beyond showing an error so that's
what we do here and this will obviously
show like a dialogue to the user so we
can at least let them know that
something's gone horribly wrong and if
the user clicks the okay dialogue then
this is where we will handle that and
this will generate a new game for the
user and again we're going to
immediately update the storage first
before we update the user interface
because the storage is the source of
truth we'll be writing the game logic
class in the next video and that video
is also going to take a little while
because it turns out it's actually
pretty complicated logic to implement a
Sudoku game and once that works
successfully then we will update the
view know so this is kind of a more
functional style of coding at least in
the try block and you know as functional
as Java can be
okay we're now going to write the
computation logic of the application and
this will take a little while so buckle
up so originally I just had a single
class here which encapsulated all of the
what I'll call computation logic called
game logic and then as I went through
actually implementing the logic required
for the various steps to basically
administer a Sudoku game I discovered
that there was a lot of different steps
involved and I broke this logic down
into a number of different classes now
the first one here we have is just like
a utility class Stokey utilities so what
it will do is it has a utility function
a static function which will copy the
values from one Sudoku array that's
passed in one two-dimensional array into
another two-dimensional array and then
it also has a second function which will
take in an old array and it will return
a new array with the same values and
you'll see that's kind of used in a
couple different places in the backend
logic of the application and also in the
Sudoku game data model itself now before
I proceed I need to explain something
really important about the usage of
static functions here in this part of
the application static methods I should
say in Java so something that I go into
a great detail on in working class Java
is how and when to use static methods
and static variables and what exactly
static means now I can't explain it here
because I need to actually explain a
little bit about how memory space works
in particular the JVM memory space in
order for you to really understand how
static works I do go into great detail
about that in the course now what I will
tell you here is a little bit about how
to use them safely you're going to
notice that I use static methods X
and Sallee in this part of the
application now the important thing here
is that I use them in such a way to
avoid what in functional programming you
would call side effects as much as
possible what I might call shared
mutable state problems so what that
basically means is that these static
functions are only going to reference
and deal with either parameters that are
passed in so for example old array here
or variables which are created within
the method body of that particular
static function and they can also call
other static functions methods I keep
saying whenever I say function imagine
method now what we basically want to do
is the way I'm using static methods here
is almost like a I heard someone else
say a poor-man's version of functional
programming but that's kind of a little
bit accurate it's about as functional as
you can get on Java so anyways I could
go into a lot of detail here and I do in
the course but I just want you to be
aware you need to be careful when using
static functions some people hate them
some people say they are horrible and
the Antichrist I don't think those
people really understand what they're
talking about there but there is
definitely some truth that there are
ways you can use static functions which
are really bad and can make it your code
difficult to test and all kinds of
things so as you can see here again
we're going a little bit functional by
having these nested method calls so the
first method we have here gets solved
game will generate a solved Sudoku game
this is going to be a little bit
complicated
this first algorithm here to generate a
solved game was made entirely by me
the will see later on there was another
algorithm which I did not create but
this particular algorithm was made by me
now the reason why I did this
it's not necessarily going to be the
most efficient algorithm in particular
later on I want to actually rebuild this
algorithm as a graph coloring problem
which that would be like an advanced
topic in data structures and algorithms
but I wanted to do something which was
hopefully as easy as I could make it for
a general kind of programmer to follow
along now I'm not saying it's going to
be easy but I'll do my best to kind of
talk you through it here so the basic
idea here first we seed a random number
generator that's what random is and then
we of course get our we create a new
grid which will be based on the
boundaries here the grid boundary which
will of course be nine so what we're
going to do is for the values one
through nine we are going to allocate
them nine times of course every Sudoku
puzzle will have nine ones nine to s
nine threes etc so that's what
allocations does it tracks the number of
times the number in the given value is
allocated this interrupt is going to
basically this is even a little bit
difficult for me to kind of fall along
here but what the internet interrupts
will do is what we'll see is kind of a
backtracking that occurs so if an
allocation is attempted too many times
then we will add basically we will
increment our interrupt variable and
then we also have an attempts variable
here which works as a fail-safe we'll
get to that in a minute so what we're
doing is we're saying okay while the
number of times we've allocated a
particular number so for example one is
less than nine keep attempting to
allocate that number if the interrupt
that is the number of times we attempt
to allocate a number is greater than 200
or sorry
I think I'm mixing that up a little bit
here yes okay so if we make more than
200 attempts
to allocate a given number so for
example 1 then what we do is that
allocation tracker thing is basically
just a list of coordinates so each time
we will allocate a number we will add
that to our allocation tracker so what
we're doing here is if interrupts is
greater than 200 then we want to go
through the past numbers the nine
numbers or whatever numbers we've
allocated and we want to reset them to
zero
so basically in simple terms we're
backtracking if we get stuck
ie interrupts is greater than 200 we
backtrack a little bit and we say okay
let's just reset to zero and let's try
this thing again now it turns out that
is not enough it's possible that even
doing that that we can just get stuck
and this algorithm will run forever
that's why we have the attempts tracker
as well if a tense is greater than 500
we are definitely stuck and what we do
at that point is we clear the whole
array we basically nuke everything and
reset it all to zero and we try again so
this is actually like a two-stage
backtracking algorithm we're writing a
little helper function here clear array
which like I say it's just a simple
array traversal and it'll reset every
element in the two-dimensional array to
zero so as you can see here it's there's
a lot of stuff going on like I said
before there's actually a way to model
this differently using a graph data
structure so that's something that I
would like to do later on but the thing
about that is it's gonna require a
certain amount of explanation and
practice and I haven't actually solved
the problem yet myself so I'll need to
do that first but hopefully now that
I've talked you through what's going on
here it should make at least a little
bit of sense and like I say it's not
necessarily the most efficient algorithm
that wasn't really what I was going for
I was
trying to make it as legible as possible
now what we do is each time we're about
to allocate a number to our
two-dimensional array we randomly select
a square by using the random number
generator here so give me an
x-coordinate that's random
give me a y-coordinate that's random now
if that particular grid location does
not equal 0
or if it equals 0 we will now randomly
or not randomly we will now allocate a
value to it if it doesn't equal 0 then
we just want to skip it because that
number has already been added in so we
don't want to overwrite the progress
that we have already made now what we're
doing here is once we allocate a value
we actually immediately check to see if
it's a valid or invalid Sudoku game will
write the game logic class shortly well
at the end of this particular s section
and so if the Sudoku is invalid then we
want to remove the value we just
allocated and then we are going to add
we're going to increment the interrupt
tracker otherwise if we did just update
a new square with a valid value then we
want to add that particular allocation
that number to our allocation tracker
and that's again just to help with our
backtracking if it becomes necessary
also we want to add to our increment our
allocations
you
and if all that works we return a new
grid now that that's done we can work on
the unsolved algorithm so this was a
really interesting thing to work on so I
wrote the unsolved algorithm but there's
kind of an interesting problem here how
do we actually know if a Sudoku game is
solvable or not so when I was writing
this unsolved algorithm I thought to
myself okay what we'll do is we'll just
randomly pick 40 numbers from the Sudoku
game and we'll just remove them we'll
set them to 0 so I you know initially I
thought that probably it would make
Sudoku which is solvable it turns out
that was not the right intuition at all
it's entirely possible to randomly
remove 40 numbers and create a puzzle
that is not solvable at all so this
poses a very interesting problem how do
I create a Sudoku puzzle that isn't
solved
hence unsolved game that is still
solvable well what I ended up having to
do is so first we do remove 40 numbers
from the Sudoku game that has already
been solved so that's that's why we pass
you'll notice whatever returns from gets
all game will basically be piped
immediately into unsolved game so also
the reason why I'm using Sudoku
utilities here is I don't actually want
to work on the original object for
solved game and that's why we're using
the copy Sudoku array values and this is
something you want to be careful careful
with if you don't really understand Java
memory space which is something I
explained extensively in working class
Java how member verian or not remember
but reference variables work anyways so
what we're doing here is were removing
40 numbers from the two-dimensional
Sudoku grid that's the first step here
and similar idea we just randomly picked
the 40 numbers you'll notice I want to
write solvable with an e repeatedly in
this particular video because for some
reason solvable sounds like it should
have an e Oh English language so what
we're doing there is we're just checking
to see did we already remove a value
there as you can see I completely
screwed that up again I don't know how I
missed that in the editing well whatever
all I meant editing is not my strong
suit okay that's a little bit better so
if it does not equal zero then we set it
equal to zero if it does equal zero then
we just loop again without incrementing
index
just making sure I'm in the right
bracket here okay so we remove 40 values
from our Sudoku puzzle now the next
thing we need to do after we've remove
those values is we actually need to
solve the puzzle again or at least
attempt to solve it so this was actually
kind of a big deal because I it's
actually not as easy as you might think
to solve a Sudoku game it's not the most
complicated algorithm that I've written
I think probably writing red and black
trees was pretty complicated for me
that's a complicated data structure but
yeah so we're gonna create again an
immutable copy to be solved and then
we're using that copy function and then
we're gonna use this Sudoku solver class
which again has static methods to
actually check to see if this puzzle is
solvable
we passed the puzzle in that we just
removed the 40 values from and then we
want to see that class their Sudoku
solver will tell us if it's solvable or
not
then we're going to jump in and go ahead
and create that Sudoku solver now just a
bit of background here so the algorithm
aim I'm using to solve a Sudoku puzzle
is called the simple solving algorithm I
actually got this from the Cornell
University website there's an article
written by called rather solving any
Sudoku now I'm not from Cornell or
anything like that but I just wanted to
give a shout out this is where I get
this now part of this algorithm was
basically doing what the person who made
this algorithm called a type writer in
numerate so what that basically means
it's a big fancy way of saying we take a
two-dimensional array and we turn it
into a one-dimensional array so what we
would do is so let's say array index 0
through 8 of the one dimensional array
would be the top row of the Sudoku and
then array index 9 through o my poor
brain 17 or whatever the hell the end
would be 18 that would be the second row
so that would be y equals 2 and then you
basically just pull out the
two-dimensional array into a one
dimensional type thing like that and
that's just a necessary step with this
particular algorithm now it's kind of an
interesting note to see how this is
where data structures and algorithms
does actually become pretty important
because one of the most interesting
things I learned when I was studying
that topic and I didn't go to university
for this stuff if in case you're
wondering one of the coolest parts about
it was you start to see that you can
take the same data the same information
represent it in a different data
structure and that can make it easier or
more difficult to solve problems in
particular I guess a really really good
data structure for Sudoku games is a
graph
structure anyways I won't go into detail
on that
now obviously here what we're doing is
we are keeping track of empty cells and
we're going to assume that the maximum
number of empty cells is 40 so that's
why we're doing if iterate iterator
equals equals 39 there and so what we're
trying to do here is we just want to
know which cells are empty that's quite
complicated isn't it
now I just want to make another reminder
here so we're using some nested loops
here again you want to be careful when
you're working with nested loops because
they can if you have two nested loops
you've got a quadratic or a square run
time complexity if you're using three
nested loops you've got cubed run time
complexity if you don't know what that
is basically just understand
do not use nested loops when the index
indexes or index I I'm not sure are very
large the number of inputs is very large
how you would say that technically is
when n is large but with the sizes we're
dealing with here it's not really a big
issue
so again we're just checking to see if
the actual puzzle is valid at any given
point in time
so basically what we're doing here is we
are checking to see which cells can't be
solved essentially and what will happen
is will eventually either solve the
puzzle or we will implement we will hit
an impasse where we can't solve the
puzzle I'll be perfectly honest I'm I
didn't actually write this algorithm and
the inner mechanics of it are slightly
escaping me at the moment
I think what it is so we get every empty
cell and we test numbers in that
particular empty cell so we test the
number one through nine and we basically
just keep adding numbers to each empty
cell and every time we add a number we
check to see if the puzzle is still
valid and so essentially we're using a
algorithm which really just follows the
basic rules of Sudoku it's going to just
kind of incrementally go through it so
now we're going to write the game logic
class
so this game logic class I'm going to be
perfectly honest with you originally I
assumed I was going to get away with
maybe one or two classes in the backend
to encapsulate the game logic as you can
see things got a little bit more
complicated than that
in retrospect what I would rather have
done here is I would rather have created
an interface and then talking spoken to
a facade pattern it's called and then
that I would have that facade called the
different static methods necessary like
I say this is one of those situations
where I really just thought it was going
to be simpler than it actually turned
out to be not to say that it's
extraordinarily complex but it's there's
a number of steps involved in getting
this thing to work properly
so the result of that is we have this
class here game logic which the first
thing I did is I encoded the rules to
figure out whether a Sudoku game is
valid or invalid and that part was
relatively easy obviously you just see
is any number repeated in a row repeated
in a column or repeated in a square or
sub grid nine by three by three grid
rather and so we have this class here
which is basically doing double-duty
it's delegating to game generator and it
is also encapsulating the logic to check
whether or not the Sudoku game is valid
or not so that's a bit of a breakage of
separation of concerns so if I could do
it again and I'm probably going to
rebuild this application in Android and
I will definitely do a better job with
separation of concerns in that
particular case it's not a big deal but
I'm just saying I'm a bit of a
perfectionist with separation of
concerns and there is refactoring to be
done so another rule we want to know to
dictate whether or not a Sudoku game is
complete is whether or not the tire
tiles are all filled so we can have a
perfectly legal valid Sudoku game but
that doesn't necessarily mean that it is
complete so that's another one of the
victory conditions here
again I'm gonna be making pretty
extensive usage of helper functions to
avoid just having gigantic functions or
methods the methods were large enough in
my algorithms now I mentioned before but
squares obviously refers to the 3x3
grids there are 9 3x3 grids that make up
the whole nine by nine nine grid in a
Sudoku puzzle now you're gonna notice
something which might seem a little bit
strange so we're going to be checking
individual rows of squares now and
you're also gonna see this rows top
that's an enum I made way at the start
in the constants class or package now
the reason why I have this enum here I
don't want you to be confused by it it
is entirely to improve the legibility
how we're going to select for the
different squares and different rows of
squares in this particular in the puzzle
is we're going to have to use
coordinates x and y-coordinates now just
in my case I found it a little bit
difficult to read and that is why I used
in ohms here to just kind of help remind
myself ok we're either talking about the
top the middle or the bottom now I think
in a general sense that is the main
purpose of enums is to improve
legibility there's different tools you
can use that are more efficient than
enums but i
there aren't many that are a whole lot
more legible than enums maybe like
static constants but in this particular
case they enum just seemed appropriate
what we're going to do here is we're
going to check the first second and
third square in the top row and then
we'll move down and do the middle and
then the bottom
now if you look up enums in Java then
you're gonna see a lot of opinions
talking about how you shouldn't use them
because they're not memory efficient I
would like to just say for the record
two things number one enums have been
optimized a lot now the thing about
performance is you can almost never
really say anything
totally concrete about performance
because operating systems differ JVMs
differ are you working with the open JDK
or the Oracle JDK or whatever so that's
the first problem
secondly it's very very rare that the
impact you will have on your program
using an enum versus maybe a more memory
efficient alternative will actually ever
be noticeable or even acknowledgeable to
the user now I'm not saying you should
use them everywhere in anywhere and make
really huge enums all the time but what
I am saying here is if you have read
something about how enums are
inefficient just understand these are
people who are basically not really
understanding the context of the
situation okay
we're saying they're inefficient that's
very often not true what you're saying
is they might be like infinitesimally
more efficient than a slightly sorry
less efficient than a slightly more
efficient option but what it really
comes down to is does it affect the
users the performance of the application
on the user side versus doesn't make
your code more legible
so what we're doing here is we pick out
the say for example the top three
squares and we add them to a list and
then we're just going to pass that list
to our collection has repeats function
here
and what that's gonna do is it's
basically going to look at each square
individually and we're just it's very
simple we're just going to see is the
number one repeated is the number two
repeated is the number three repeated
etc and that's how we kind of dictate
whether or not the particular square is
valid now zero can repeat that's fine
it's just the other numbers that we're
concerned about and this just comes from
the rules of Sudoku in case you're
wondering and we're going to use a handy
little function there to make that a
little easier collection stock frequency
that comes from the Java standard
library
okay so now that we've got the top row
configured here we will work on the
middle and bottom rows
now I just need to point something out
here there is a slight mistake with the
X index and the Y index those are
actually supposed to be reversed so the
0 0 0 the 3 3 3 and the 666 those are
supposed to be Y indexes which would
indicate the top middle and bottom again
when you're doing this amount of
rewriting a whole bunch of code there's
gonna be little mistakes like that but
just understand those are supposed to be
reversed now checking for whether
columns or rows are invalid is very very
easy we just look through the each grid
each row or column in the grid and we
again see if there are any repeat values
now this is again something where we're
gonna see I create another function
called method called rows are invalid
and the code is going to be very
repetitious and that's actually a sign
to me that I should probably apply some
abstraction here and basically pull that
code into one single method but
unfortunately that didn't really occur
to me until I was busy recording this
thing so it is what it is they're not a
big deal but again this is just me being
an absolute perfectionist when it comes
to abstraction and separation of
concerns
and all that's going on here for every x
value we will add all of the Y values
and we will just check to see again
using our helper function collection has
repeats whether or not it is actually
valid and I misspelled collections has
repeats so we'll just fix that there and
then we'll code the function for rows
now like I say this is a place where the
codes very repetitious so that's usually
a sign like I discuss in my course that
there's some refactoring in order to fix
that but yeah just thought I would point
it out
luckily I managed to fix that particular
error that would have been buggy and
that's basically it
so what's happening now is we're just
some of the static functions actually
need to be public because they're used
in different parts I could probably make
them protected this was a particular
case where as being lazy about my access
modifiers but you know in actual like
production code I would not just leave
them public just an FYI there
chances are at some point you've heard
the term dependency injection or you've
heard about the service locator pattern
and you might have wondered what these
things are actually about there's a more
technical word which I really don't like
to describe this but my favorite teacher
for software architecture Martin Fowler
describes it incredibly well he states
essentially that we are applying the
principle of separating configuration
from use I in my own terms I would say
that an object which uses other objects
should not also build those objects you
should pull the logic required to build
those objects into a different class or
function or something like that or
method I should say so that's basically
what's going on here we're taking the
logic required to basically wire up all
the different actors in our application
together just before they launch for the
user to use and we're encapsulating that
into its own special little area of the
application and the good thing about
using interfaces is that we can use
these interfaces within our build logic
itself here like as you can see the user
interface is being referred to or
referenced as its interface same as
storage etc etc now oftentimes we do
need to refer to the concrete names when
we're creating things like a new local
storage imple but yeah you get the
general idea here so visco what this
class does is we attempt to get the game
data from storage if it exists now if it
doesn't exist then what will happen is
the storage class which will write in
the next part will throw an exception an
i/o exception if that's the case then
all we do is we just ask game logic for
a new game we update storage if possible
and then down below here is where we
will actually bind everything together
so the first thing we're doing here is
we're creating our UI logic class the
control logic class and that thing
requires storage and our reference to
the user interface in order for it
do its job properly just gonna import
that by the way I'm hitting alt enter to
import there and then we need to of
course bind the control logic class to
our user interface so that they can talk
both ways finally we call this method
which will basically update the board
with its initial State and things will
start it'll start the ball rolling
that's basically it okay so the last
thing we'll do is we will implement our
storage mechanism that's often called a
persistence mechanism persistence just
means persisting data in case you're
wondering that could be referring to
something like a database in this
particular case what we're doing is
we're actually just going to be writing
a file to the local file system in order
to store the data so of course I have my
I storage interface which I will
implement by hitting alt enter and we
have two methods which we need to
implement now what we'll write up here
is something which is a file type
reference variable now basically what
this is it can be a bit confusing but
it's more like a path or a URL rather
than thinking of it as the file itself
so system X dot get property will
retrieve the operating systems kind of
home directory and this child argument
here will be the actual name of the file
that we store so of course in the users
home directory we will store a file
called game data dot txt now we'll use
this file object both for storing and
retrieving the data in case you're
wondering so the first method here
update game data will of course write to
the local file system in order to do
that we will use output streams so the
first stream will be a file output
stream
and streams are basically just ways it's
about streaming data either in and out
of the operating system or there's HTTP
URL stream in Java if you want to stream
data from the interwebs but yeah this is
the most common way to like sort of
write files and we'll also need to
create an object output stream as well
I'm going pretty slow here with the
typing because there's a whole lot to
type here and it's kind of complicated
now why are we doing an object output
stream as well so our Sudoku game class
if you recall extends a I forget if it's
a class or an interface but one of the
two called serializable and so what that
does is it basically allows us to
serialize that class which means turning
it into like a easy a data format which
is easy to read and write in this case
to a text file even and that just makes
it easier for us to read and write that
data there's other things you can do you
could read and write to a JSON object
but in this case serializable was the
quickest easiest way for me to get the
job done and that's often a good
solution if for some reason the file
doesn't exist or rather if if we try to
update the game data and we're not able
to we're just going to throw an IO
exception obviously the message there is
a little bit generic but I'm not super
concerned about that now when we want to
actually read the data from the file
system then we're going to use input
streams so it's almost identical except
we're just using input stream instead of
output streams again we'll use the game
data file as a way of finding our
resource
as you can see it's very very similar
now if for some reason we can't locate
the file generally speaking because it
doesn't exist so if it's the first time
the user has run the application then we
will throw an exception now this might
be an important little thing to mention
here exceptions don't always need to be
critical errors you want to think of
your exceptions is basically being of
two different kinds so if you're having
like a nullpointerexception that's going
to obviously crash your application
whereas things like io exceptions I'm
not sure why I wrote class not found
exception that is probably a typo there
that should probably say IO exception
but if you have something like an IO
exception it might not actually be like
a fatal error it might be just a way of
basically using it like a control
statement if it exists do this otherwise
do that so you okay I do actually throw
the IO exception there which is good so
anyways that's basically all we have to
do and then everything will work
beautifully thank you for joining me in
this tutorial if you would like to learn
a lot more about programming and in
different languages than just Java then
check out my other tutorials and courses
available across the web I maintain a
YouTube channel where I host live Q&A
sessions when I can and I am active on
many different educational platforms
such as you to me skill share and more
this tutorial is dedicated to my friends
Haemon dewater Marek de ho bitsy Chetan
guard Jaime Corkhill Al Warren and the
countless other people who have helped
me build my skills as a developer and to
share that knowledge with others peace
out y'all I'm Odie